I didn't want to mention this we have we
got a big crew and you know I try to
keep everybody happy it can be tough so
right now we're gonna do a brand new bit
on the show we call stagehand complaints
this is where I take complaints from
stagehand all right let's get two of our
stage hands out here right now Bruce and
Ronny
[Applause]
[Music]
I have a complaint and I am a stagehand
okay I don't know what is going on can
someone please send our casting director
out here right now please
amazing job boys you were really good
Esteban
okay all right yeah Kathy Kathy Kathy
yeah I want to talk to you about your
casting choices for this sketch sure
what's up okay I was hoping that it
could just be you and me talking oh okay
take five guys okay Kathy twitchy one
more photo not the khaki please stop
hugging Esteban not really okay no it's
not okay for this sketch I wanted two
guys that look like stagehands those
guys look nothing like stagehands I'm
not sure I follow
okay Kathy our stage hands are just
regular guys when you cast young male
models to play them it takes everybody
out of the sketch it's distracting and
it's not just tonight remember that
sketch we did a few weeks ago about the
release of the iPhone 6 and that sketch
that we did about the Lincoln
assassination remember that one
it was a good one that was a good selfie
that Lincoln was amazing what about that
sketch about the new Jurassic Park movie
I mean they just wasn't right I think I
get it
it won't happen again all right good now
let's try it one more time and please
just cast a couple of realistic-looking
stagehands
got it I will take care of it very good
thank you so much okay this is good as I
was saying here's a new piece we're
calling stagehand complaints Bruce
Ronnie can you come out here
[Applause]
[Music]
now that's what I'm talking about
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you